le mot que vous détestez
très cher
bonjour Patrick tambez bienvenue comment
allez-vous bien bien merci allez on
commence sur votre gauche avec un retour
en arrière un classique avec vous que je
vous laisse commenter
ça c'est
une Ferrari
en 1983 une victoire
merci de me faire ce plaisir et ce
cadeau voilà je suis tombé en panne dans
le tour de décélération trois Français
sur le podium moi au centre et puis René
Arnoux à ma droite et puis et puis à la
Prost c'était un moment d'une intensité
immense vous me donnez des frissons
c'est vrai sur l'ensemble de votre
carrière de pilote quelle course quelle
expérience vous a amené le plus de joie
celle-ci évidemment bien sûr la première
c'était au Grand Prix d'Allemagne
l'année précédente au lendemain
d'accident très très grave de Didier
Pironi je me retrouvais seul pilote
leader de l'équipe Ferrari et puis sur
le plan carrière même en dehors de la
Formule 1 il y a eu beaucoup de
d'expériences sportives intéressantes
mais le pari Dakar aura laissé pour moi
un grand grand souvenir alors depuis que
vous êtes élu au conseil général des
Alpes-Maritimes vous êtes membre de la
commission sécurité routière sur votre
droite
ce petit livret les élèves vont devoir
le potasser sérieusement s'ils veulent
être un jour automobiliste au même titre
qu'un livre d'histoire de l'essentiel de
la sécurité routière c'est de
d'informer d'éduquer
les jeunes collégiens au danger de la
route donc avec cette distribution du
Code Rousseau pour les aider et les
préparer déjà préparé leur attestation
de sécurité routière de premier degré
deuxième degré je crois qu'il faut
travailler peut-être même encore en
amont le plus tôt possible les
transports la déclaré il y a quelques
semaines les Français ont fait des
efforts mais il y a encore 5000 morts
chaque année sur les routes dans la
région PACA comment ça se passe
c'est une responsabilité collective
c'est évident je crois que on doit
tous faire preuve de beaucoup de de
sagesse se rendre compte que l'on a
entre les mains une arme et que l'on
peut
va être le criminel soit être la victime
de d'incivilité sur la route nous
passons tout de suite aux questions
rapides c'est parti pour une minute
votre principal trait de caractère
la sincérité l'honnêteté
gourmand votre occupation préférée
mon fils votre livre de chevet
[Musique]
j'en ai quelques-uns en ce moment je les
entame et je ne vais pas au bout de
temps c'est ça non c'est que je m'endors
très rapidement le mot que vous détestez
très cher celui que vous aimez
amour la personnalité que vous admirez
[Musique]
votre devise
ne rien lâcher et enfin votre rêve de
bonheur
la santé de mes enfants et leur réussite
on passe sur votre droite s'il vous
plaît que vous inspire ces images
[Musique]
aucun sport ni échappe aucune loi n'a
plus l'endiguer la volonté d'aller
toujours plus loin et le sport business
sont conduits les athlètes de haut
niveau à recourir à la pharmacopée alors
en l'occurrence on va parler de dopage
est-ce que lors de votre carrière vous
avez connu
non j'en ai bien sûr entendu beaucoup
parler
autour de nous ça n'existe pas que je
sache en tout cas dans le sport
automobile mais je ne suis pas certain
que
ça soit bien de rester naïf à ce sujet
là dans le sport automobile je crois et
je pense qu'il est important de
contrôler de surveiller et bien sûr de
savoir je
crois que je crois que c'est arrivé
bon vous êtes déjà approché ou pas tout
au long de votre carrière non non pas
pas de cette manière mais enfin j'ai été
allez je vais être sincère puisque je
disais tout à l'heure la sincérité et
l'honnêteté c'était mon trait de
caractère j'ai j'ai été témoin de
certaines de certaines pratiques
la langue découvrir votre objet vous
avez choisi un casque c'est le vôtre
ça peut être le mien en tout cas ça y
ressemble c'est le casque de mon fils
Adrien oui c'est un futur champion oui
il travaille
assidûment c'est un fait beaucoup de
sacrifices il apprend le métier la route
est longue
alors j'y connais pas grand chose BMW on
dit comme ça il est en Formule BMW en
championnat d'Europe en ouverture des
Grands Prix de Formule 1 et il a entamé
la saison 2008 de manière magistrale il
a fait un carton plein lors du premier
meeting avec deux points de positions
dans oui oui il a le numéro 27
le voici
c'est mon numéro fétiche numéro qui
était le mien chez Ferrari qui était
celui de Gil Villeneuve qui était
que j'ai croisé tout au long de mon
existence très très souvent qui m'a
amené beaucoup de bonnes choses alors il
a il a souhaité le porter quand c'est
possible il le demande Patrick tomber
merci beaucoup
alors vous êtes élu
UMP soutien Nicolas Sarkozy le président
nous a-t-il déçu durant ce début de
quinquennat
ah c'était la question subsidiaire et
plus écoutez bon on en reparlera dans
quatre ans je reviendrai volontiers si
vous voulez me réinviter puis on fera on
fera son bilan ensemble mais là déjà au
bout de ces 14 mois
je crois que il était nécessaire de s'y
atteler de s'y atteler de manière
agressive et offensive ça ne plaît pas à
tout le monde c'est évident et ça peut
déranger aussi beaucoup mais attendons
de voir s'il
atteint ses promesses Patrick tomber
merci
[Musique]